Film Courage: Have you ever pitched to one
of the studios?
David Willis, screenwriter/producer: Yeah,
I pitched to one of the indie studios once
a particular script, I mean I pitched to them.
But this one particular indie producer, I
was brought into a meeting to pitch to him
by another producer (who was a woman) and
she says “Come meet this guy and we’ll
pitch him this movie.”
So I came in, I pitch him the movie, and it
was a romantic comedy and the male character
(the lead character) starts out with one girlfriend,
breaks up with her and ends up with another
girlfriend by the end of the movie.
And the reason I bring that up is because
to pitch it (this guy, this executive) he
says “So is that what your life is like?”
“What do you mean?”
“Well this guy, he’s got all these women
in your movie.
He’s got all these women!
What the hell is going on?”
And I go “He has one girlfriend and he gets
another one.
I don’t think that’s really a lot?”
And he says “I don’t know, that sounds
like a lot to me.
He seems like a womanizer, that’s what he
seems like his life is like to me.”
And I’m like “Oh, okay?”
This anger was coming at me.
And I’m like it’s just a weird meeting.
Anyway, so we leave and the woman producer
that I came with she goes “I apologize.”
And I go “What’s going on?”
And she goes “Well…I’ve been dating
him and he wants to be exclusive and I don’t
want to be exclusive…”
So all this guy was doing was sounding off
at me as a way of telling her you know “Why
won’t you me exclusive to me?”
That’s really what the meddle was about.
That was the weirdest pitch meeting ever because
it had nothing to do with me, you know?
And some times it’s out of your control.
What can you do?
You just do you job, pitch, pitch, pitch,
smile, do your job and that’s it.
Film Courage: At least she was there to tell
you that because you wouldn’t have known
otherwise.
You would have thought it was you.
David: And I was not dating her by the way.
Film Courage: No, no, no.
I get, I get it.
But at least someone was there to tell you
because so many times things like that happen
and there is any for it and we’ll never
know!
But at least you got to know that.
So when you when in to do other things [pitch
other projects] that experience was always
in the back of your mind and maybe it’s
totally not about me, but I don’t have that
woman there telling me the story as to why
someone is acting this way?
David: One of the first pitches I did, I came
in with a pretty famous writer.
We’d written something together and we were
pitching at Paramount.
And as we were pitching, he was talking and
we had this long, super complicated, really
detailed pitch that we thought was wonderful,
he was describing it.
And as we’re pitching, as we’re telling
the story, the guy (this executive) he starts
to do this [David Willis imitates a man falling
asleep].
Film Courage: Oh no.
David: And after awhile we realized “We’re
putting him to sleep!”
Film Courage: Oh no!
David: We’re putting him to sleep!
And you know, we’re comedy writers so we
stopped and we started talking about it but
what a note to get!
“You’re putting me to sleep.”
We actually, literally, this guy and so that
was like a huge lesson for us…we learned
keep the pitch short.
We went into all these frickin’ details,
you know?
So we’ll never forget that one.
Film Courage: Yeah.
Well, there was no note-behind-the-note.
You knew what was going on with that one,
okay?
David: Indeed.